من جهتها قالت وزاره الدفاع الصينيه ان
اقدام واشنطن على اسقاط المنطاد المدني
بالقوه رد مبالغ فيه معربه عن احتجاجها
شديد واضافت الوزاره ان بيجين تحتفظ بالحق
في استخدام الوسائل اللازمه لتعامل مع
المواقف المماثله
انا الان من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره احمد
هزيم ومنبجين مراسله الجزيره شيماء جوي
رحب بكم وابدا معك شيماء ما الذي يمكن ان
يضاف حول ردود الفعل الصينيه في هذا
الاطار
ازدهار عبد الصمد اليوم ردود الفعل
الصينيه تاتي على اكثر من مستوى نتحدث عن
رد فعل على مستوى وزاره الدفاع الصينيه
قبل لحظات من الان التي اكدت في بيانها
بان رد الفعل الامريكي من خلال اسقاط
المنطاد الصيني المدني بحسب الصين بالقوه
هو رجل رد فعل مبالغ فيه قدمت ايضا وزاره
الدفاع الصينيه احتجاجا رسميا للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مؤكده بانها ستتخذ
اجراءات مماثله في ظروف او في احداث
مماثله في المستقبل ولم تتحدث عن
الاجراءات او الخطوات او تفاصيل ما ستقوم
به الصين ترد فعل على اسقاط المنطاد الذي
تؤكد الى حد الان بانه مدني وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه في وقت مبكرا من الصباح
اليوم بعد اسقاط المنطاد في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والذي كان قد تزامن مع
التوقيت المتاخر جدا في الصين تقريبا
الفجر في الصين اتى رد فعل وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه
مقتضبا ايضا لكن كان شديده اللهجه عندما
قال بان الصين سوف تتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه
لحمايه الشركات الصينيه ذات الصله المدنيه
وقالت ايضا بانها تتخذ اجراءات وخطوات
للرد على قيم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
باسقاط المنطاد الصيني هنالك ايضا استياء
شديد بحسب تعبير وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
مما اقدمت عليه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه خصم وان الصين كانت قد حاولت
خلال اليومين الماضيين منذ ظهور قضيه
المنطاد الصيني في الاجواء الامريكيه على
ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه وذلك من خلال
ما اعلنته وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه عن
مكالمه هاتفيه جرت بين مدير اللجنه
المركزيه لشؤون الخارجيه الصينيه وان هي
ووزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن
والتي قالت الصين بانها قد اكدت ان كل
التحقيقاتها تؤكد بان المنصات للارصاد
الجويه والابحاث العلميه وليس منطاضا
للتجسس وانه دخل بالخطا الى الاجواء
الامريكيه الصين قالت بانها تدرس السبل
والطرق التي ستقوم من خلالها باعاده
المنطاد واخراج من الاجواء الامريكيه يبدو
ان الخطوه الامريكيه الان التي اتخذتها
باسقاط تثير
غضب الصين وايضا تثير حفيظه اليس فقط
وزاره الخارجيه الصنايبر ايضا وزاره
الدفاع ربما ستكون الايام المقبله ازدهار
اكثر توترا بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والصين خاصه وان الصين كانت قد
وجهت تحذيرات سابقا قبل ظهور قضيه
المنفصاد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بدايه الاسبوع الماضي وذلك بعد توقيع
واشنطن ومانيلا الاتفاقا يسمح للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه باقامه اربع قواعد
عسكريه جديده في الجنوب الصين ما يساهم في
تطويق الصين من جهه السواحل الجنوبيه
بالتالي ربما نتوقع توترات اكثر في الايام
المق